inspired by the concepts of you cap 10
years ago some folks in Silicon Valley
thought there might be a better way to
capture facial geometry other than
gluing reflector dots to your face fYI
the gluing on isn't the bad part it's
the peeling off hmm instead mova uses
phosphorescent makeup applied with a
sponge strobing fluorescent lights and
an array of 32 cameras instead of
capturing around 100 points on the face
mova creates an animated mesh with
thousands of points this offers digital
recreations with all the subtle and
dynamic motion performed by the actor
you would have seen this used most
recently for josh brolin playing Thanos
in the blockbuster guardians of the
galaxy tim carter Roger Van der lon ken
Pierson Greg lassalle the Academy
presents you with a technical
achievement award for the innovative
design development and integration of
the mova facial performance system
gentlemen come on
well I brought my drink in case I savox
oh [ __ ] Thank You Margo miles and miles
happens to be a mova alumna for
Fantastic Four I'm honored to speak on
behalf of the people that have been
involved with mova over the last ten
plus years besides Tim Roger Ken and
myself there are two other people that
I'd like to acknowledge the
contributions of they are Steve Perlman
and John spec Jon Jon's here you should
stand up John
I'd also like to thank the original San
Francisco crew of Ken Wendy Mike and
Paul a really big thank you to all of
our clients the visual effects companies
that have continued to use mova as part
of their facial pipeline and the many
actors who have George Clooney put it
have been movin a special thank you to
digital domain for supporting mova over
the years and for helping us see what
mova is capable of doing and lastly I'd
like to thank the academy for this great
honor thank you Oh voxel I just want to
thank my wife for letting me chase a
dream and not getting a real job I'd
like to you know thanks Steve Perlman
you know I think you're the smartest
hardest working guy I've ever met John
spec also the rest of the team my mom
and my beautiful wife Kenzie thank you
this thing was so much work and I'm
exhausted but totally worth it so thank
you to the Academy ditto everything Greg
said and a big thank you to my wonderful
wife Josie my awesome kids Eliza DD and
Andrew thank you
you